[Música]
Hola Esto es África siete días el
magazine de la actualidad africana
bienvenidos comenzamos con titulares
la situación humanitaria en Sudán está
llegando a su punto crítico los combates
entre el ejército y los paramilitares no
cesan millones de sudaneses están
atrapados por los enfrentamientos y el
sistema sanitario del país se está
uniendo
se trata de una de las peores masacres
desde 2015 en
la localidad de karma en el norte del
país del ejército acompañado de
paramilitares ejecutó al menos a 150
personas entre ellas mujeres y niños los
militares acusaban a los habitantes de
complicidad con los yadistas La Isla
francesa de mayor situada en el océano
Índico es escenario de intensas
tensiones las autoridades y gran parte
de la población culpan a los migrantes
que proceden principalmente de la vecina
como horas de la inseguridad y de la
delincuencia
abrimos esta edición en Sudán donde
continúa la guerra entre el ejército y
los paramilitares millones de ciudades
siguen atrapados por los bombardeos el
conflicto que comenzó el 15 de abril le
enfrenta al ejército del General
y su antiguo número dos el general
Mohamed daggle al mando de los
paramilitares de las fuerzas de apoyo
rápido el conflicto ha dejado más de 500
530 muertos y más de 5000 heridos según
cifras oficiales que están ampliamente
subestimadas los gobiernos extranjeros
han conseguido evacuar a sus ciudadanos
y los udaces cuando pueden intentan huir
según la ONU que teme que una nueva
crisis migratoria desestabiliza aún más
una región ya inestable
75.000 sudaneses son desplazados
internos mientras que al menos 20.000
a Sudán del sur 3500 ha hecho vía y 3000
a la República centroafricana otra
preocupación es la situación sanitaria
según la Organización Mundial de la
Salud La ya profunda crisis de los
hospitales en Sudán se ha vuelto
catastrófica escuchemos al director
Regional de esta organización en la
región
hay una verdadera escasez en el sector
médico desde que empezó la crisis hace
15 días sobre todo especialistas como
cirujanos y anestesistas
hoy escasean los fondos y los
suministros médicos debido a la falta de
seguridad y a la dificultad de acceso a
los hospitales
en cifras cerca del 61% de las
instituciones médicas de jartum han
dejado de funcionar además de los
ataques militares directos la ocupación
militar de estas instituciones y el
despido de su personal el 23% de los
hospitales de artum funcionan
parcialmente Y solo el 16% funcionan a
pleno rendimiento Esta es la situación
sanitaria en Sudán especialmente en las
zonas de conflicto y en lo que respecta
a la situación del pueblo sudanés hay
casi 16 millones de personas es decir un
tercio de la población que se benefician
de una ayuda humanitaria que cesará
debido al actual conflicto en Sudán se
trata de una de las peores masacres
perpetradas por el ejército contra
civiles en burkina faso desde 2015 según
el alto comisionado de la ONU para los
Derechos Humanos al menos 150 civiles
entre ellos mujeres y niños fueron más
sagrados el 20 de abril por miembros del
ejército burkines ayudados por
paramilitares la matanza tuvo lugar en
el pueblo de karma en el norte del país
los militares la habrían cometido tras
acusar a los habitantes de complicidad
con los yadistas a continuación el
testimonio del portavoz de los
ciudadanos de karma
el pueblo fue rodeado a primera hora de
la mañana por hombres fuertemente
armados con uniformes militares
burkineses montados en motocicletas
camionetas y vehículos blindados al
principio los habitantes se alegraron de
su llegada pero su alegría se vio
rápidamente truncada por los disparos
los habitantes huyeron entonces la
mayoría hace sus casas pero fueron
capturados por Los pistoleros y
agrupados varios fueron ejecutados in
situ incluidos los heridos que
intentaron huir y comprenden
algunos grupos de personas fueron atados
y golpeados duramente antes de ser
ejecutados
otro grupo de unas 20 personas escapó de
las masacres gracias a algunos soldados
que les perdonaron la vida
bebés murieron sobre las espaldas de sus
madres ejecutadas la carnicería duró más
de seis horas antes de que los soldados
abandonaran el pueblo en dirección al
pueblo de dinguiri fatiga
los supervivientes pudieron salir tras
su partida mientras que algunos de los
heridos fueron transportados al centro
de salud otros no pudieron ser evacuados
y murieron
en total 147 personas murieron en karma
entre ellas 28 mujeres 45 niños de entre
nueve días y 14 años y 9 heridos en los
pueblos de los alrededores murieron
nueve personas todos hombres
en respuesta a la violencia que asola
pasó desde 2015 El capitán Ibrahim
traoré que llegó al poder tras un golpe
de estado de septiembre de 2022 Apuesta
por una lucha antiterrorista Ultra
ofensiva basada en el armamento de
decenas de miles de ciudadanos pero
desde entonces las matanzas de civiles
no han cesado continuamos con la
entrevista a un investigador del centro
de pensamiento
realizada por nuestro colega Search
Daniel sobre la militarización de la
sociedad civil en burkina faso
Quién mata a quién en esta zona
hay que tener en cuenta a todos los
actores pero en cualquier caso está
claro que en mi opinión lo importante es
que la acción militar se ha llevada a
cabo exclusivamente por las fuerzas
armadas y no por civiles armados a los
que el estado incentiva en esta batalla
así se vería claramente quién está
matando y a quienes están matando pero
en realidad Cuando los civiles son
armados por el gobierno nos encontramos
en un contexto de transformar la
sociedad civil en milicias Y eso causa
sobre todo desgraciadamente esto
confiere al debate una dimensión étnica
lo que permite a los grupos terroristas
seguir extendiéndose Y ser muy
virulentos
recientemente algunos testigos dijeron
por ejemplo que vieron llegar a hombres
vestidos con ropas del ejército regular
le preocupa esto es que estamos
tenemos que ser capaces de controlar
todas las acciones de los militares por
eso me opongo con gran vehemencia a la
participación de otros actores que no
sean los militares en este conflicto
vamos ahora a la isla de mayot
departamento francés situado en pleno
Océano Índico frente a las costas
africanas desde hace semanas La Isla se
enfrenta atenciones sociales sin
precedentes según las autoridades y gran
parte de la sociedad civil los migrantes
que proceden principalmente de la vecina
como horas son los que fomentan la
violencia y la delincuencia en el país
en respuesta el gobierno francés lanzó
una operación denominada wambushu Que
consiste en una serie de intervenciones
policiales para destruir varios pobres y
expulsar a los migrantes indocumentados
es una antigua Colonia francesa cuyos
habitantes optaron por seguir siendo
franceses por eso la isla atrae cada año
a miles de migrantes como lo vamos a ver
en el siguiente informe para muchos
ciudadanos
es la única opción para una vida mejor
estamos en la isla como orense de anyuan
la más cercana a la isla de mayong
en un día claro desde este Rincón de las
comoras se puede ver mayor La Isla
francesa con sus escuelas y hospitales
es un sueño al que miles de comorenses
intentan llegar cada año endomoney Los
Pescadores fabrican sus propios barcos
de madera los cuasa cuasa embarcaciones
diseñadas para llevar pesca que sin
embargo a veces vuelcan cuando van
llenas de hombres mujeres y niños en
busca de una vida mejor por unos cientos
de euros estos Pescadores transportan a
los numerosos candidatos a la migración
este hombre se justifica para él se
trata de ayudar a los enfermos a ser
atendidos en mallot ya que el sistema de
salud encomodas es muy deficiente
me hubiera gustado dejar de ser
contrabandista no es fácil ni los
beneficios no son elevados pero es ayuda
mutua una prescripción divina los
guardacostas nos molestan se muestran
impasibles a pesar de que transportamos
pacientes que no pueden curarse aquí
pero mayor en realidad es el
departamento más pobre de Francia
asolado por una explosión de inseguridad
y delincuencia en los últimos meses
Francia ha intensificado la lucha contra
la migración una controvertida operación
denominada wambushu está en marcha para
expulsar a los migrantes indocumentados
de los barrios pobres
de 52 años vive al otro lado de la playa
en esta pequeña casa tres veces ha
intentado la travesía pero tres veces
fue de vuelta sus tres hijos se quedaron
en mallot hace 15 años que no los veo
sufro porque a veces no puedo
contactarlos por teléfono cuando tengo
la oportunidad de hablar con ellos me
dicen mamá Esto no es vida ni siquiera
podemos encontrar comida así que sería
mejor que volviéramos pero les impedí
volver porque es mejor vivir en mallot
que en las comoras mayor pasó a ser
francesa en 2011 y en las comoras se
sigue considerando como orense pero para
ti duamir el cordón debe ser cortado
según ella si Francia Tiene que dejar de
expulsar a los comorenses de mayot los
comorenses también deben Dejar de soñar
con ir allí
cambiamos de tema La ilustradora y
autora de cómics camerunesa
estuvo en la Feria Internacional del
Libro de Bogotá para presentar la
exposición itinerante esta exposición
sobre las narrativas gráficas de África
reunió la obra de 50 artistas nuestra
periodista cultural lea Israel
entrevistó a Joel manden y le preguntó
sobre su percepción del vínculo entre
África y América Latina durante su
visita a la capital colombiano
porque desgraciadamente ya sea América
Latina o el resto del mundo o África
siempre hay muchos tópicos o prejuicios
pero un país es mucho más que tópicos o
prejuicios y lo disfruté mucho
podría decirse que me alegré de no dejar
que los prejuicios guiaran mi percepción
de Colombia así que llegué aquí y estoy
encantada sinceramente encantada los
intercambios son de una calidad muy alta
así como el encuentro con el público uno
siente Una curiosidad muy sincera
please
los intercambios son muy interesantes
Porque además en el marco de esta feria
del libro el tema son las raíces y
cuando me encuentro colombianos que me
explican que sus raíces son indígenas
españolas y afrodescendientes y que veo
a mi nivel Qué efecto de Espejo tienes
tú en mí como persona o como comisaria
de exposiciones
es apasionante en términos de
experiencia personal y profesional
así termina el programa de esta semana
Gracias por acompañarnos la actualidad
internacional continúa en Francia 24.com
[Música]